it looks and feels a little like
corporate America like a power
presentation with Microsoft or Facebook
but this is a bitter autumn in Paris and
brand Europe has a crisis to think
through how to tackle sky high
unemployment how to draw in disenchanted
unemployed voters there were many ideas
out there you know sir jee bhar de
distribución phone co sog ducret lick on
dco juridique economic development on
top Anaya social event will monde des
emploi du GU Rome a position cancion de
minato classical alegre had the shortly
Chandra's bad condition making short of
Eleanor's they sell koo kumba get this
was the first part of the road show
which the European Parliament is staging
before elections next year to connect
voters to issues high on the list
unemployment eleven percent of the
working population in Europe are out of
a job almost twenty-five percent of
young people any PS believe they've done
a lot to alleviate the problem in the
youth guarantee scheme recognition of
qualifications Erasmus and support for
redundant workers yeah nouveau oh ho
piya o sa question on booze on a
three-day pass casino mr. District
Attorney system the protection social
national a un oiseau de paula question
ishow Masha tell care suppose said to to
see son cosas but any peas are also
painfully aware of the increasing yer of
extremism and populism as a direct
result of unemployment it's a
threatening danger in the sense of
democratic stability in regions in
europe where the people might have lost
already confidence in solidarity and
confidence in the ability of governments
to solve problems they suffer on one
thing though everyone agrees innovation
and entrepreneurship are the key to new
job creation much of it in energy and
the environment next stop for the
roadshow is the Polish capital Warsaw
for a discussion about Europe and its
place in the world